australian woman explains why new york
city men have the best dating game
they don't
okay tease on that one let's see though
australian dating columnist jana hawking
came to new york to observe how
australian men measure up
to the what is that blokes
is that how they say it
yes okay back up people nodding in the
background
the blokes whatever back home here's
what she found
this is what she says
something really stood out to me new
york blokes have got game
and not in a bad f boy [ __ ] boy kind of
way they i love when they added stuff
more to charming hey why not give it a
shot kind of way as i perused a shop i
watched as a very stereotypical new york
guy caught eyes with an attractive shop
assistant and boldly said hey baby girl
what are you doing later
bold
how lame is that first what is going on
by the way in australia if you think new
york city men have game
you're in trouble australian men i don't
know
she goes on to say what is specific
about new york guys that stands out for
her
and it's one word for her
confidence okay so let me tell you
something i grew up in new york city i
was in new york city my entire life
except for a couple of years in florida
when i was like
three
so
new york city my whole life new york men
are known throughout the country
i'm sorry if you're in newark i'm not
talking about every single new york guy
you're you're i see already in the chat
somebody's gonna be like i'm from new
york i don't do any of that i get it
but i'm talking about most some of the
worst
guys to date in the country
are in new york city everybody will tell
you that you will hear women all the
time from the northeast saying you got
to get out of new york you got to get
even go to new jersey just do something
to get out they are the worst guys to
date i'll tell you why first of all
they're not gentlemanly
at all
they're not they're not gonna open your
car door they're gonna look to split the
bill i'm telling you straight
okay
they're not gonna come drop you off pick
you up at the front door none of that
stuff i mean maybe they'll hell a cab
for you you're gonna pay for it honey
nine out of ten times you're gonna pay
for it they'll open that door maybe hail
that cat and be like ah see you later ah
yep you know what you're not gonna get a
call either making sure you got in okay
at the other end you're not going to get
a call believe me i have a ton of single
friends right now in new york city
you're not going to get that call maybe
you'll get a text
the next day
okay maybe
maybe
okay so they're not gentlemanly i wrote
a little list for myself to remind
myself they're very self-absorbed
very self-absorbed
there's a lot of this
all the time
you're on date you're not on a date
extremely like
obsessed with the whole look going on
okay
they take more time than you to get
ready in the bathroom oftentimes
i'm not exaggerating it's not an
exaggeration
there's a delayed we talked about like
delayed adolescence there are overgrown
babies so in texas for example like
you're a man they grow boys into men by
the time you're 23 you're a man in texas
you're expected to act like a man you're
expected to behave like a man
that's like 40-something in new york you
go through all of your 20s and all of
your 30s like an overgrown baby i'm not
kidding around you you're out in the
club i can't tell you how many times i
would go to the club in my like early
20s and i'd see like
near 50 year old guy there just like you
know chilling like he's
he never got out of college
he's still doing that thing and i'm not
talking about being 50 and you're out
with a bunch of friends and going out to
a lounge at night and you know it's your
night and have i'm not talking about
that you know who i'm talking about
everybody can spot that guy in the club
who's acting like he's 22 and it's sad
it's a sad situation
there's a lot of them in new york city
a lot of them
and also they're not she's saying
they're confident they're not
they're not confident at all some of the
most insecure men because they're always
hiding behind a phone they rarely come
up to you in person there's a lot of
fear that goes into that equation i
don't know where she was hanging out i
don't see a neighborhood here
uh yeah i don't see a neighborhood
mention i just see new york city i i
would love to know
but that these are not qualities that
you're going to hear in new york women
be new york you know where new york
women go to find their men
texas
they go to the midwest
they go to texas and i'll tell you a big
difference it was interesting i just did
a guy that lived in chicago uh outside
chicago his family lived in lake forest
lovely family gorgeous home like
beautiful beautiful family and um
i remember that
his friends were so gentlemanly
but they were like chicago guys and i
was like well that's a city right
it's a blue city
what's so different and he used to say
to me
hey this is the midwest
like you can't behave like that over
here
it was fantastic and it was a moment
where i was like that's true
so yes they occasionally you will see
like my husband's from new jersey
not like this
you'll see if the further you get from
new york city the better luck you have
they'll go up women will go upstate
they will hop on planes to meet men and
most of the time when they really decide
that it's time to settle down they move
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]